here's a really beautiful video by Megan
Kelly now Megan Kelly who you know I
adore Megyn Kelly obviously and we've
done many shows together over the years
and everything else uh Megan Kelly not
only talks the talk but she walks the
walk Megan Kelly lived in New York City
during covid and all of the woke lunacy
that we have experienced over the last
couple years her kids school went
insanely while pushing the gender stuff
on all on her children she has three
three relatively young children and she
got up and left she did what I did I
moved across the country she left the
state of New York and she has just had
it with not only the wokesters but the
big tech people who were in cahoots with
them to silence us
I dare you I dare you to de-platform me
Apple I Dare You I Will Rain hell down
on you for a woman speaking up for girls
and for her fellow women and our rights
to be safe and to have our spaces I dare
you I will unleash hell on that company
I will actually lead protests in the
street I will go to the outside of Apple
headquarters they cannot do it they
can't they will live daruga I will make
them a Bud Light if they try to shut
down these conversations because we are
finding our voices and we're getting
help from men right Matt Walsh has been
amazing all the guys at Daily wire and
so many others and the the audience I
mean people are figuring it out right
now after girl after girl gets hurt
woman after woman gets hurt loses money
loses safety loses something so I don't
think that they're that they can do that
I really don't I don't she means it she
means it I know Megan well enough she's
not just saying it she will do it so
that is the challenge if you're if
you're a YouTube employee and you're
watching this right now and you're not
happy because I said this or that or
because we've titled our videos one way
or another or everything else you know
one of the things is and and one of the
reasons that I'm always encouraging you
guys to move over to rumble is because
the more of you that move over to rumble
the less important YouTube will be right
like that's the key part of this every
people are like well why do you do
anything on YouTube then and it's like
well there's still there is still a
discovery element of YouTube it just is
but I want to make sure that if today if
today was the day and don't think it
couldn't happen remember they remember
they took Trump off all the platforms on
one day so don't think it couldn't
happen don't think the powers that be
uh couldn't just all sit down in a room
and say you know what today's the day
let's take out the daily wire Channel on
YouTube let's take out Reuben let's take
out Megyn Kelly let's take Al Crowder
and let's take out you know five other
people let's just take them all out
bongino's already gone from YouTube
altogether right so it could happen at
any moment and that's literally why I
started local so please even if you
don't want to throw a couple dollars in
if you want to just join so that we can
always directly contact you because I
can send push notifications out to you
reubenreport.locals.com it's absolutely
free to join and be part of the
community if you want to engage a little
bit more it's a couple bucks a month
anyway that's on that but the point is
there there are alternatives
foreign
[Music]